we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P this caller has a really
interesting question do these Mega
people genuinely not understand what
Free Speech means or are they only
pretending
hey good question why does the right
seem to always complain about Free
Speech when they're talking about
private companies are they intentionally
saying that because they know that Their
audience doesn't really know what Free
Speech actually is right or they
themselves don't know what it means yeah
it could be either one this is a really
great question so often
these right Wingers will say this is an
issue of the First Amendment even if it
did you see that thing pop up I don't
know if that was just on screen a little
clip related to one of my cables just
literally popped up like like a uh like
a like a jumping bean of some kind I
wonder if the video caught that we'll
have to review the footage later
um two different parts here one they
often say there's a First Amendment
issue when it has nothing to do with the
government the government and the First
Amendment related Twitter doing
something not related to the First
Amendment secondly do they know the
difference between Free Speech or
um moderation it's not clear that they
do I genuinely don't know the answer
there are some slightly more informed
right-wingers
who understand the difference between
free speech and First Amendment and just
moderation but they will say platforms
like Twitter and Facebook have become so
large that they are essentially like a
town square and they should be regulated
as if they were government entities
interestingly that's pretty heavy-handed
from the regulation perspective
so at the end of the day I don't know
what right-wingers do and don't know are
they ignorant are they arguing in bad
faith is it some combination of the two
you be the judge we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the Elon Musk Twitter CEO situation
we're going to talk about Madison
cawthorne being sued by his own lawyers
for not paying them seems like that's
going around in trumpism and we will
talk about Alex Jones salary request as
part of his bankruptcy proceedings wild
wacky request sign up at
joinpakman.com get instant access to the
world famous and award-winning bonus
show